you have to be all in and it's the
hardest thing to do because if it fails
then you can feel like a failure i think
of this idea of performance necessity
two stories kind of come to mind one is
i was working with an olympic gold
medalist sprinter and we're in the
tunnel and we're going out and he's
talking about the competition and we get
out to the blocks he was really worried
about the competition i said well how do
you engage like who who who's going to
win you know in his particular race
people are winning by you know 1 100th
of a second tenths of a second i mean
these are really close sprints and i
said well how how do you know i said who
would you even bet on and he says you
know i would
bet on the guy
who gets down at the blocks gets himself
settled looks at the finish line and
says
i gotta do this
for my mom
and i was like ooh
that's good his performance necessity in
that is
it's necessary for him to win that race
for his mom wanna be happy build a life
not just a business hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel is created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's leave your best believe
life and learn the seven steps for
massive success
enjoy
when i started
my career and i really decided to go all
in
with writing and online training
this is like 2 000 probably six
uh i'd gone broke completely bankrupt
and failed i left my corporate job i had
this cushy kind of corporate job as a
consultant good job um left it to write
and i didn't know how to make it as a
writer i want to do seminars workshops
didn't know how to do that so i was
pretty much a hot mess ran out of money
um i got nothing to my name
nothing kind of no positive prospects no
one's calling me except the guys who
want the money
and um
one night i'm riding and the apartment
was so small on the bed i had
uh
you know my bills my vision boards all
my research
all my journals like the bed was
basically the desk the extended desk
and my lady comes in denise and
she
walks past me but she sees i'm like
trying to write so it doesn't disturb me
she goes she
crawls under
the covers of the bed and i'm just
typing kind of casually typing away
and i look over
[Music]
and
i see my woman
sleeping under my bills
and it was just like
you know
because none of us want to see our you
know
our family suffer because we are
not performing sure
and um
i was just like
i gotta figure this out
and i'm telling you i wrote more that
night than any night in my entire life
next day i wrote more than ever that
bird's life
and ticket which became a best seller
and in you know 18 months later because
i was like i'm going to figure out this
online thing i'm going throughout
marketing i'm going to figure out how to
teach i'm going to how to train and get
paid for it because i'd never really
been paid for those things i said i'm
going to figure out this industry and
i'm gonna make it 18 months later after
her
crawling under the bills i made 4.6
million dollars jesus online
total transformation people like how did
you do it i'm like she gave me she was
my necessity i was not going to let my
woman
be in that situation um
and she believed in me she supported me
she she married me
and uh you know but that was she was my
drive and the second part was i went all
in with my identity i said i am going to
be
a great writer
and i am going to be one of the greatest
online trainers there ever was step
number two keep on learning with naveen
jane every time i am trying to learn
something i go deep into it so i read i
read probably 15 to 20 books on the same
subject if you read one book the
author's view becomes your view when you
read 15 books in all different point of
view you can create a view which is
different from all 15 and that is the
key so one of the trick i use actually
is very interesting is that until two
years ago i didn't know anything about
microbiome so what i did is i created a
twitter feed of everything to do with
every scientific journal that has
anything to do with microbiome and i
have 50 or 60 of them and every day in
the morning i get up at 4am every day
and i go through my twitter feed i read
all scientific journals
and you can do that for neuroscience you
can do it for cancer and you can start
to do that for every single thing so i
use the twitter feed to learn about the
subject rather than following trump step
number three create your time with grant
cardone this concept of time management
has been pushed off on me my entire life
and i have never ever agreed with it i'm
like why would i want to manage time
why would i what am i going to do how do
you manage time what do i do i like okay
i'm going to watch these seconds dude i
don't want to manage time i want to
produce i want to be highly productive i
want to squeeze time i literally want to
take time and i want to turn 60 minutes
into three hours of production that's
the different thing that you need today
not manage time now there are some
tricks when managing time if that's
where you want to come from like alan
greenspan alan greenspan and his
roommate in college his roommate's
father
taught alan greenspan a little trick
that alan greenspan used his whole life
and it was to break up the day into 15
minute blocks
15 minutes i have something and then
fill up the next 15 minutes now the
reason alan did that and i like that
concept a lot is because he didn't want
white space on that calendar he knew
white space was a problem because
white space nothing in the 15 minutes is
a waste of time
see before you start thinking about just
managing time first i want you to do
this number one i want you to make a
list of things that you're doing every
day that is a waste of time that is the
way you create time not manage it
the first thing i want to do is look at
things that i'm doing that are wasteful
those two or three hours a day that are
wasteful moments things i'm doing on
facebook that just a waste of time or
maybe a game i'm playing that's a waste
of time or maybe
a newspaper i'm reading where i'm not
really learning anything i'm reading
about the the celebrities it's a waste
of time okay second thing i want you to
do is this i want you to then start
thinking about these 15-minute blocks
and filling that calendar up but the
third and most important thing i want
you to think about is how can you create
time
how can you literally take 24 hours and
and pack more into it so that you can
become more productive so that you can
use that urgency concept and really blow
up your your career blow up your life
make the most incredible life for your
family for you for the kids for your
wife or your husband and for your
clients so that you can take care of
yourself materially as well this is
grant cardone thank you and hey remember
don't manage time
create it
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there step number four take ownership
with leon howard the key to building
wealth is not how much you can work
you can't work your way to wealth you
got to invest your leader and all
wealthy people black white asian chinese
they own a whole bunch of
the people who aren't wealthy is because
they don't own nothing
you only have your money sitting in cash
if your money is just sitting in cash
realistically you're becoming poorer
every day
right or they own depreciating assets
and that's what cash is it's a
depreciating asset because the more
money they print the more money that
money loses value so if it's just
sitting it's the reason why the bank
wants you to have your money there so
they can take it and use it and invest
it so much and be like hey this is
sitting i'm gonna give you 50 cents on
whatever you had in it
and so the idea of ownership was yo we
can just start owning
everything that we no matter if it just
a stock
like that's powerful because if you can
start owning the businesses that you now
consume every day you turn a one-time
transaction to a lifetime of profit
and that was major for me because if i
go to the store and buy a pair of nikes
that's a one-time transaction in order
for me to get something from them again
i got to come back and buy another pair
of nikes but if i own the nike stock
long as i own it it's a profitable um
vehicle for me so that one-time
transaction can become a lifetime of
profit if i own that business if i'm
gonna buy apple if i know i'm an apple
user if i know i got the phone i got the
error pods i got the macbook i got the
pc i got i excited when apple's about to
drop something why wouldn't i own it
as much of it as i can
right like if i if i understand that
concept if i know people gonna america
has one of the biggest trash problems in
the world right so if i know that waste
management is a company that's gonna be
here forever because we aren't gonna
stop throwing things away why don't i
own that company
because i know everybody throws things
away and so now instead of me getting
excited about apple lime being around
the corner because it's a new phone i'm
like yo y'all have to make me some money
right so when i hear a company like
waste management has bought 40 acres of
disposable land for another landfill i'm
excited about that
and another great thing about the stock
market is
for me it now makes me pay attention to
the world
and so now i understand what's going on
in the world i started learning business
cycles market cycles you know i'm like
because now i can understand yo
this is okay things are going out of
business it's okay we're in this cycle
okay people are hiring okay we're an
expansion cycle and so now i started to
take i took an economic class on my own
without
just understanding the world and so you
start understanding when something is
happening in china okay something
happened in china so i own apple apple
has 20 revenue in china okay they might
take a little hit right now
you know what i'm saying so the stock
market helped me start understanding how
the world moves the fundamentals right
right and so that's important step
number five prime your brain with john
ashraf if i hadn't discovered
how to retrain my brain to change my
results
chances are i would have ended up in
jail or the morgue
now for me i had a very successful
mentor named alan brown
and alan took it upon himself to show me
many of the secrets that wealthy people
understood which allowed them to have
what i think is almost a magical ability
to set and achieve goals
and it can seem impossible to achieve
those same goals to people who don't
understand how the process works
and so as part of my training
alan had me do something
i think it's very interesting what he
had me do is he had me write down
one
extremely specific goal
with a date associated with it of when i
would achieve it
but then he asked me to do something
that seemed i guess pretty boring since
i was 19 years old and it seemed
redundant to do it over and over again
but he had me read this goal
every single day with my fingers
scrolling on the words of the page
he told me
to do my best to feel the words with my
fingers now i know it may sound crazy
but he wanted me to feel the world the
the words and he wanted me to imagine
that what i had written down
was true
and that the goal that i had written
down one goal one date
was becoming a reality for me so he had
me in essence
read
put my fingers across the words and see
myself moving towards those goals and
what he shared with me is that when you
see
read and feel this goal in this way
you're actually sending an electrical
signal
to your brain from your finger up your
arm to your brain
which does what
it makes you much more likely to achieve
this goal
little did he know that what he said
would later be 100
validated by
neuroscientific discoveries
let me explain there is a term in the
brain research the science field that
goes like this
the neurons brain cells that fire
together
wire together
what this means is that when you
activate by hearing seeing running your
finger on your goals
when you activate and wire the different
brain cells together they formulate a
pattern
the more you reinforce that pattern the
more it becomes a strong
automatic
pattern in your brain
that causes you to think feel and do
things differently so your reality
changes now on any given day you have 30
40 50 000 thoughts popping up in your
head
some of these thoughts are caused by
internal influences such as your
memories your beliefs
habits that you have
others
are caused by external influences like
texts you receive
facebook cell phones traffic bird flying
across you know the sky
into your window
these thoughts cause your mind and even
mind to be scattered all over the place
most of the day with no clear direction
or focus
and so
if you think of your brain
as an organ right
i'm gonna pull my brain from right over
here i've got a brain okay right over
here it's not my brain but it's a brain
if you think of your brain
as an organ that you could put to work
for yourself like a loyal servant
then
what you also need to do is you need to
direct it and if you don't it'll just
wander all over the place with no idea
what you actually want
so if your goals are scattered so will
your focus be but as soon as you set a
goal
and choose to consistently
and consciously focus on it your brain
realizes that this is important to you
and then what happens is it starts to
automatically notice ways to bring you
things that you want from the
perspective of teaching you how to focus
on it and this is one of the best ways
to activate and create a new pattern in
your
non-conscious brain which you've
probably heard a million times is where
your real power is
when you set a goal that excites you
you're activating a part of your brain
called the nucleus accumbens and the
insula now this is closely related to
the motivational center of your brain
which is responsible
for releasing the feel good chemical
dopamine and even some adrenaline to get
you going to achieve your goals and
dreams and this is like activating your
go muscle
when you review your goal by seeing
reading and emotionalizing
achieving this goal
you're in essence giving your brain
clear instruction and specifically when
you repeat it over and over again
this goes from your conscious thinking
brain to your non-conscious brain and
when you do this for one day seven days
30 days 60 days
you are basically differentiating
that goal
from the 30 to 50 000 other random
thoughts you have daily
and when that happens you're
using your brain by instructing it what
to use the non-conscious power center
for
so the question is does this work
a study at the dominican university
found that people who simply and clearly
write down their goals are 42
more likely to achieve them
now if you want to know something even
more amazing
you can
supercharge the process and the
automatic neurological response your
brain experiences when you do this one
thing ready
find a big reason
why
you must achieve your goals
for example
you might have a goal
to
earn or get a specific amount of money
let's say you want to earn
thirty seven thousand dollars six months
from now or fifty thousand dollars a
year from that the the amount is
irrelevant
whatever your goal is just by doing that
and writing it down
and reviewing it you're more likely by
42 to achieve it but when you write down
three reasons why you must
achieve your goal not want to but must
achieve your goal
your brain realizes wow this is really
important and when you turn on that
motivational part of your brain the
motive for action is your why let me
repeat that
the motive
for taking action is the why
this is one of the many simple ways to
start training your brain
to automatically think feel and do more
of what you want and less of what you
don't want to do now you may have heard
that if your why
doesn't want to make you cry because
it's so emotionally positive for you
where
achieving it is going to make you feel
so amazing about yourself and your life
and being proud and having meaning in
your life
maybe you have the wrong goal or maybe
you just haven't gotten fully associated
with the deeper reasons
why you want to achieve your goals i
remember
my parents struggled so much when i was
younger
there's an old saying that goes like
this there was always too much month
left at the end of the money and i
remember my parents
fighting about the lack of money in our
in our lives and how they couldn't
afford this and couldn't afford that i
remember that i hated that feeling but i
hated even more the fights and the
arguments that they had throughout my
childhood and i made a decision when i
was very very young
that i would never do that but even more
than that
i made a decision that i was going to be
able to retire them
in a way that they felt proud and
meaningful and loved and and and that
was really one of my biggest reasons why
when i was in my 20s and 30s and 40s was
to develop the skills and to be able to
use my mind the right way to retire my
parents and thank god for for me my
brother and sister we've been able to do
that and my parents are in their 80s now
and the feeling for me of going back and
remembering my why one of my big whys
has transformed the way i think and feel
and how i achieve my goals and dreams
and so
can you just associate for
one minute think of one big goal that
you have it could be for yourself or for
your children for your family or your
extended family what's one thing that
you want to achieve get that in your
mind for just a moment
now i want you to
think and then feel why why
would achieving that goal
make you feel so phenomenal why
and what i think you'll discover is when
you can dig a little bit deeper and find
a big reason why
you'll find the motive for your actions
and that's
just a really good tool to use anytime
get totally emotionally connected to
that what i'd like to share with you is
i love studying the brain i love
studying how this works how does
motivation work how do the fear circuits
stop us from achieving our goals whether
it's fear of failure or fear of success
or fear of disappointing you know
yourself or fear disappointing a loved
one
and what i've done by studying the brain
for the last 35 years
and also connecting
with some of the most brilliant brain
researchers in the world
is
i've put together something called the
brain-a-thon
and
we've got seven of the world's leading
brain experts
who are really amazing at showing people
how to number one recognize what may be
holding you back
is it self-doubt is it lack of
confidence is it lack of certainty is it
past traumas you've had in the past
is it your lack of knowledge or skills
on how to really achieve your financial
and life's goals that's holding you back
what are the mental or emotional
resistance points that once you remove
them get rid of those as obstacles
would allow you to put your foot on the
gas and really just achieve more of your
goals and dreams step number six
eliminate a fixed mindset with tom
bilyeu i am reading mindset the book by
carol dweck and i'm sure you've talked
about it before but i'd love to hear any
personal examples of you having to
overcome the fixed mindset i believe my
long history of a fixed mindset has led
to a plethora of self-sabotage disbelief
in myself and a fear of failure so deep
that it's paralyzing okay well the good
or bad news is that i can completely
relate to that and here is the reality
no matter how
successful the person is that you're
looking at and wishing you could be like
them and thinking that they have
everything all figured out the one thing
that i can promise you is that all of us
struggle on the inside that is just a
reality of the human condition once you
understand that that is a reality that
that's just a part of the human
condition then you can begin to ideally
let yourself off the hook and that
you're not spending a lot of time
stuck there but to give you a specific
example from my life the biggest one the
most harrowing one that i went through
was in film school so
uh
to cut a very long story short i went to
film school believed that i had innate
talent i went into film school with a
fixed mindset
i did very well at the beginning of film
school and that all to me felt like it
was proof that i was right that i was
naturally gifted that i was a born
storyteller and that i was going to go
and have an illustrious career and i
actually went through a fascinating
period in film school where i was both
terrified that secretly i wasn't good
enough and but at the same time actually
believed that i was naturally gifted and
this is what i was meant to do and every
bit of feedback that i got in either
direction was
it made me believe to the core of my
being that it was true so when i would
do something poorly i would think see
that part of me that was convinced that
i actually don't have talent you were
right and then i would do something well
and the part of me that believed that
was like see i knew it you were born for
this
and it all came crashing down as i work
my way up the ranks at usc film school
only four people are chosen to direct
what's known as a senior thesis film or
a 480. and i was one of the four people
picked and i was like see i knew it man
i'm born for this of course i got picked
to do one of the senior thesis films
that just makes sense i'm i'm that good
and i thought okay cool the thing that
makes the thesis film so important is
the film school pays your budget to make
this film so at a time where there's no
youtube there's no iphones like filming
is an expensive endeavor here you've got
somebody that's paying for it and that
becomes your calling card to the
industry so george lucas famously made
one of these films and obviously we know
how his career ended up working out and
they showed us his 480 by the way and it
was amazing
it was amazing and so
you could see that here was this gifted
filmmaker
and so i have that in my head like look
at george lucas's films absolutely
brilliant he's gone on to have this
brilliant career i'm gonna make an
equally brilliant film or maybe a little
more brilliant and then i'm gonna go
become the next lucas or the next
spielberg and i'm gonna take that film
and get my three picture deal
and
i proceeded to
run smack bang
into one immutable truth
and that was that i wasn't a talented
filmmaker
and i don't say that to be humble i say
that out of truth because i didn't have
the skill set to make a good film once
the level of complexity had gone beyond
a certain level so i had thrived in
these really short really simple films
and then once you're talking actors and
dialogue and you know the things that
would come close to what we would
recognize as a normal film uh
i had no idea what i was doing
and
try and try as i might i couldn't figure
out how to make the film come out well
and it didn't come out well and i was
mortified and i was embarrassed and i
never wanted anybody to see that film
and i was really and truly devastated so
i want you to imagine your whole life so
what i graduated at like 22. so
from 12 to 22
all i knew was i wanted to be a
filmmaker and my whole life was moving
towards that and it looked like i had
the natural gift and of course if you're
going to be an artist you're either born
with it or you're not right that's all
anybody said i can't express enough
in the 80s and 90s when i grew up
when people talked about art you either
had it or you didn't and that was that
there was no sense of growth mindset
carol dweck had not written the book yet
and so it wasn't even like i knew there
was a growth mindset and a fixed mindset
i just knew you're either born with it
or you're not
the great news was i was born with it
here we go it's going to be amazing and
then boom i can't do it and i realize oh
my god i wasn't born with anything i
don't know how to do this there is a
tremendous amount of process to this art
and i don't know that at all but of
course as i'm in the middle of it i just
think my world has come crashing down
i'm not gifted i will never be gifted
and therefore i will never be a
filmmaker i will never make anything of
myself and just it was a downward spiral
of epic proportions
and
at the height of that
i would
go home from my dead-end job
and i would lay
face down
on the carpet because i couldn't afford
furniture
and
literally just sit there i can still
feel
that cheap nylon carpet and the way that
it felt on my face
as i laid there thinking well
my life is effectively over certainly
the
my life that was working towards a dream
is over
and
now it's just about finding a way to uh
be the smartest person in the room
and if that means that i have to go and
work a dead-end job to be the smartest
person in the room then that's what i'll
do and so i used to go
and interview for jobs having nothing to
do with film
because i felt totally broken and
my goal was to at some point in the
interview have the interviewer say
you're so smart why are you interviewing
for this role
and because i had a fixed mindset and i
so needed that praise from the outside i
was putting myself in these super weird
and
useless positions just to get that
little nugget of oh my god like you're
so smart
and i had to put myself in sort of worse
and worse company to get to that point
and
finally and i don't remember what it was
that
led me to this idea of brain plasticity
but somewhere in the depths of my
despair i realized
can we get better maybe we can
and so i started reading about the brain
and that started to plant seeds in my
mind that maybe brain plasticity was
real and maybe i could get better and
just because i wasn't good at film today
maybe i could get better at film down
the road and i ended up getting a job
teaching film because remember those
that can do those that can't teach so i
felt like okay well i can teach this
even if i can't do it
and then so between reading about the
brain and realizing wait a second
if i work at this thing i actually get
better my brain actually changes and i
become better at something and
given you know having gone through
however many years of schooling i'd been
through i started thinking about like
wait a second you would come into any
class and the funny thing is as a kid i
remember every grade just being
absolutely terrified that well i did
okay being a fourth grader but mom i'm
gonna get devastated as a fifth grader i
don't know what i'm doing and no matter
how many times my mom would console me
and say remember they're gonna teach you
how to learn the things that a fifth
grader needs to know they don't expect
you to already know it it just wouldn't
sink in and so i was sort of back in
that moment of
you know i don't know how to do this
but maybe
my mom is right maybe the
neuroscientists are right and maybe i
can learn
to become that thing i want to become i
start teaching film
and as i'm teaching it i realize wait
i'm helping my students become better
filmmakers so if i can help them become
better filmmakers and brain plasticity
is really true then i could get better
as a filmmaker myself
and that
that realization changed the rest of my
life and this is why i
am so obsessed with the idea of
a growth mindset and brain plasticity
because the biology backs it up
and once you understand it's what i call
the only belief that matters the only
belief that matters is that if you put
time and energy
into getting better at something
you'll actually get better
and that those skills have utility so
learning how to make a better film
means you can actually make a better
film and more people will go see it and
be moved by it and they'll pay for the
tickets and they'll buy the plush toys
but that all came down to you went and
got good at telling stories you went got
good at making movies but it was a skill
set that you garnered now of course
we're not blank slates so some of us are
going to learn that process easier and
typically when somebody learns something
easier we say oh they were born with it
the reality is well they may have had a
they get a disproportionate return on
the amount of time that they spend
studying that thing but the reality is
they still have to study that thing and
so you don't find people achieving just
levels of greatness you know even take a
lebron who the amount of time that he
spends
working on his craft making sure that
his body's in peak physical condition
reading the game all of that
he has to do all that even though
he has also incredible natural talent so
it can be useful to look for areas where
hey i
have a love for this thing and i'm good
at it
i get a disproportionate return that's a
better way to think of it that when i
put energy into learning this thing i
get maybe 1.3 x
return on that versus somebody else who
might get a 0.7 return but what i want
everybody to understand is you get a
return
and so once you understand that you get
a return it may take you longer you may
have to work harder than somebody else
but if you love it enough and you want
to be that thing then you can become
that thing and so that was exactly how i
got myself out of that downward spiral
and working my way up to feeling good
developing confidence and understanding
that now
if i can get good at anything that i
want
then how i spend my time becomes a
spiritual consideration
and when you approach life like that
like i can be good at anything maybe not
the greatest of all time maybe you need
like that disproportionate returns thing
but you can get
i'll just i'm gonna start saying you can
get a hundred times better at anything
that you pursue right
if you can get a hundred times better at
anything
imagine how that will change your life
if you pick something that matters to
you and helps other people and you get
100 times better at that thing over the
course of 40 years than you are today
that is a game changer it will change
your life it will change your financial
situation it will change your emotional
situation everything about your life
changes when you realize you can
dedicate yourself to getting good at
things that matter and step number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is prioritize things with j
shetty when i'm out speaking at
conferences companies and universities
one of the most common questions i get
asked is how do i know what to focus on
i've got so many ideas there's so many
things that i want to do how do i know
where to put my energy this is often the
answer that comes to my mind straight
away and it's something that i've
practiced that has made a huge
difference i call it the rule of three
at any stage in my life i always have
three things that i'm investing in that
are there for my growth these are new
ideas new areas of growth that i'm
excited by or maybe even something i
want to learn but i always try and do
three new things for example i could be
testing a new video format i could be
speaking at a whole host of new
different companies that i've never done
before and the third thing could be that
i'm learning a new skill that i've never
tried the thing is that our brains and
our mind find it easy when we're trying
to work on three things now the
incredible thing about this especially
done strategically is that you'll find
momentum grow in specific areas more
than others if you're starting to see
that one of the places that you're
giving a lot of time and energy is not
really growing replace it for something
else knowing when to substitute
something for something else is all
about this keyword momentum momentum is
something you can't buy it's something
you can't create it's when things start
flowing in the right direction for you
when you're constantly working on the
rule of three you'll find certain things
that will grow far faster than other
areas so if you're thinking to yourself
you've got so many ideas there's so many
things you want to do and achieve try
and narrow it down into the top three
priorities these are your top three
strategic areas that you're investing
your energy time and effort
make your calendar your life this is how
you start to live an intentional life
because you've designed it you've put it
in your calendar not just the business
things when we think about a calendar
it's usually your business stuff okay i
got a meeting here i gotta i gotta send
my newsletter out i have to whatever the
things are for your business life right
you're if you're an entrepreneur you
probably have some of your business
things put in your calendar i'm not
talking just about that i'm talking
about your life
talking about how do you live an
intentional life by structuring
every day
what ends up happening inside of that is
oh my gosh that's too much structure i
can't stick to it
that's too it's too overwhelming i need
free time i need free time in my
calendar great put free time on your
calendar
if you know that you need two hours a
week to have nothing in your calendar
okay
then when is that gonna happen
this is how you reduce stress and
anxieties because you've actually
scheduled in your two hour break
and nothing else comes in because when
you don't schedule your break here's
what happens
other things are going to come up that's
a priority other people's emergencies
other people's phone calls and texts and
emails and social media and then what
does that what happens you lead back
down to stress anxiety overwhelm
you block off your time you build your
your ideal life
i was talking entrepreneur yesterday who
i'm mentoring
and he he
his business blowing up his business is
blowing up it's amazing um on his way to
seven figures it's crazy
and he's struggling with his health
he's going to doctor's appointment
struggling has lots of inflammation
and
okay so you need to you need to eat
better you need to work out more you
need to have a kind of healthy lifestyle
you you already know this i'm not
telling you anything new
but it's on his calendar so he loaded
his calendar and his calendar is all of
his business stops like okay well where
are you
where's the physical activity in your
calendar
and where are you prepping
for the meals that you're gonna eat
because when you just show up
on a
good morning hey have a great day
awesome okay now you're really hungry
there's nothing healthy in the fridge
what do you do you go for you go for
junk or you go do takeout
because you didn't plan because it
wasn't in your calendar
you need to schedule it you need to
schedule when you're going to go buy
food if you're going to order out
how many times a week do you want to
order out schedule this stuff in as
jocko willing says discipline equals
freedom
you want this life it's entirely
possible
but you have to have the discipline in
your calendar to actually follow through
on it
when you find yourself not following the
calendar
it's because of a couple reasons the
first is because
you set goals that are not actually
possible there wasn't enough flexibility
in your calendar right that you say how
many times you set a goal and he said
i'm going to work out every day for for
two hours
and then and then what happens you don't
because it's unrealistic because that's
not gonna happen
and what you're also doing is training
yourself that you suck that when you set
goals that you don't follow through
that's a problem
then the next time you set a goal you're
going to
tell yourself oh i'm not going to do
this one either because i always set
goals and don't follow through you don't
you stop believing in yourself it's not
even other people believing in you you
don't believe in yourself because you've
taught yourself that when you do so when
you say you're gonna do something you
don't actually do it that's a problem
so how do we start to fix that we start
to fix that by actually creating a
calendar that reflects our entire life
so think about your goals let's let's
break this down right step one think
about the life that you want what's the
life that you want
how much time do you want to spend
sleeping how much time you want to spend
with family how much time do you want to
spend this will change right if your
husband and wife single kids
anybody sick in a family those will
shift our calendar accordingly but right
now think about your life right now how
much time do you want to spend with your
family how much time you want to spend
in your business how much you want to
how much time you want to spend
do you need for yourself
free time or meditation time or working
out time or going out in nature time how
much time you want to spend
planning that as opposed to randomly
hoping that your day happens as you want
it it's not
having no plan and no schedule is the
path to stress and overwhelm
having a decent plan
even a poor plan at the beginning starts
to create the momentum that you need so
think about how much time you want to
spend in those categories because you
don't want to spend all day sleeping you
don't you don't want to spend all day
with your family you don't want to spend
all day with your kids with your husband
wife you don't want to spend all day
working you don't want to spend all day
relaxing either like the idea of work
sitting on the beach might be great
right now because you feel stress
overwhelmed and may hate your life but
you don't want to spend all day every
day at a beach you would get so bored
the trick is not to escape your current
life because then you're going back to
it right
escape for two weeks the life that you
hate to then come back to it the trick
is to build a better life and that
starts with an intentional calendar so
think about how much time you want to
spend
on the different categories
then step two i would split it up
between
things that you need to do daily and
things you need to do
either on a weekly or monthly basis so
daily is daily routine so i have a
morning routine i'll wake up i'll put on
music i'll set the intention for the day
i'll go for a walk outside it's the
snowing in toronto this morning i still
go for my walk outside i'll do some kind
of workout whether it's swimming or yoga
some kind of workout and then i'll start
my day
right what i do is start my day like my
business day
those are different days of the week
okay so just do morning routine and then
evening routine so we bucket these but
these are mostly the same every day
evening routine
uh i'll eat dinner with nina at six i
have blocked off an hour to be able to
spend time with her at seven i'll stream
on my gaming youtube channel answering
questions from you at eight i'll spend
time with my son hayden usually playing
minecraft or catching up or doing
something together nine will sit down
and watch a show with nina right now
we're watching wheel of time on amazon
10 i'll take the dogs out
i'll come back up i'll clean the dishes
and whatever else needs to be clean in
the condo 11 o'clock i'm getting ready
for bed reading the book
and hopefully passing out right evening
routine pretty structured pretty similar
every day
what it does is make sure i have time
for all the stuff i want to have time
with my son i want to have time with my
wife i want to have time to eat dinner
and not be stressed out and rush into
the next thing i want to make sure that
there's still time to
do family admin stuff like take the dogs
out and clean the place because
sure if i miss it one day
everything would be fine but if every
day i'm not taking the dogs out and not
cleaning up the place that's going to
cause strain on my relationship with
nina and also not being happy with
myself right so all these things are
designed now that structure may sound
overwhelming and crazy for you awesome
you have different goals
maybe you need four hours of open time
every night or four hours of meditation
time every night don't don't take my
calendar i'm just giving you an example
you need to create your calendar for
yourself
so what's your daily morning routine and
daily evening routine put it down create
it
then inside of the week you might have
different different things on different
days i structure my entire day so
monday's mentoring day i just mentor my
team tuesday is youtube day where i'm
filming content today's a tuesday i
don't know when the video comes out for
you but for me i'm filming on a tuesday
wednesday is my project day it's totally
open to work on projects that i want to
work on thursdays public facing days
interviews podcasts shows etc so tuesday
thursdays are busy this i'm not being
creative i'm just work work work work
work work work work
very little free time
and i'm doing tons of videos and tons of
interviews wednesday in the middle is
totally open
like okay
all the ideas that i've had all the
projects that i've wanted to do here's
my time in my calendar to do it because
if i didn't have that spot then i would
feel again stressed out overwhelmed i
feel like i'm just answering all these
messages and just creating content and
just going on people's shows and i have
no time to create my own stuff perfect
wednesdays done right wednesdays i would
use to write my book
it's the whole day totally open friday
is my ceo day
where i work on the business instead of
in the business
saturday is fun day
so saturday if i'm doing anything that's
work related it has to be cleared
through nina first and better be
something big so i lose out on some
opportunities because saturdays is fun
day and then sunday is family admin day
cleaning up the condo grocery shopping
costco whatever whatever needs to get
done
that's my life
right that fits for me let me be the
total worst thing for you it probably is
awesome figure out your life
morning routine
evening routine your entire life not
just what you need to do as an
entrepreneur for your business but for
your life as a husband or a wife or a
son or a daughter or a parent your life
time you need for yourself
create it
morning routine evening routine and then
the rest of the week what are you gonna
do
it matters this is how you start to
build consistent habits
the next step is to
evaluate at the end of the week how well
you did the whole point isn't to beat
yourself up of how you sucked and how
you miss this and schedules don't work
for you etc but to evaluate it's not
that you can't stick to a schedule it's
that the schedule wasn't a good enough
schedule for you
so what needs to change in the schedule
for example for dinner for me
these are these micro tweaks you might
have to make a big tweak but a micro
trick for me was i had my dinner
from 5 30 to 6 with nina
and it just felt too rushed because okay
well we don't usually take an hour to
eat we eat small meals so we usually eat
it pretty quickly
so okay half an hour perfect easy enough
time
but it kind of felt rushed getting into
it so even though it doesn't take us a
full hour to eat i book off an hour to
eat that's an example of a micro
adjustment so think about where do you
feel stressed out in your calendar
you've done it for a week right you plan
out your calendar for the next week
perfect morning routine evening routine
what happens during the week during the
day perfect
you evaluate at the end of the week
where did you feel stressed
where did it not work out
where did you miss something
and if it's a one-off thing okay fine
something happened but if it's happening
consistently
then your calendar is broken
then you need to spend more time here if
you get to the end of the week and you
feel stressed out overwhelmed what are
you feeling feel like oh i don't have
enough time to myself this is what the
the the person i was mentoring yesterday
said it's like i look at your calendar
if i couldn't do that i have no time to
myself
great schedule in time to yourself
because if you don't schedule in time
for yourself chances are something's
going to jump on top of it and you'll
never have time for yourself i'm giving
you the answer
so where is time for yourself
well saturday morning perfect how much
time you need four hours great
put that in give yourself five hours as
a buffer just in case now you've got the
time
and protect that time
so it's making those micro adjustments
as you go and so your first week if
you've never done this or feels
overwhelming or stressed for you the
first week is probably going to be a
disaster that's okay
you did some of the things that's better
than not doing any of the things
so let's make some progress now at the
end of the week
look back and iterate
change it make some micro tweaks okay
that clearly didn't work here okay so
next week i'm gonna try doing this and
what you do is get closer and closer and
closer to creating the schedule that
actually fits for who you are
for your goals
and it's not going to be my schedule
it's not going to be steve jobs schedule
or jordan peterson schedule anybody else
it's going to be one that you designed
tailored for you and then the third last
step to it is you're going to grow and
change as a person and your schedule
needs to change and adjust alongside so
there's a very big difference between
having a job and being an entrepreneur
there's also difference between being a
solo entrepreneur and then having a team
there's a difference in having five
people on your team or one person to
five people to
37 people now for me there's a big
difference in how i need to manage my
time i didn't i have a whole day
dedicated to mentoring i didn't need
that when it's just me
right things have to change
if you're
single versus in your relationship or
single versus engaged versus married and
how long you've been married
or if you have kids or not or planning
to have kids right like your your
choices will change as you change as a
human so even if you create the perfect
schedule right now for yourself and
that's reflective of today like it's the
perfect schedule for this week right now
chances are in a couple months you're
gonna have to make some micro tweaks
because
something's changed in your life and
that's okay that doesn't mean that your
schedule sucks it just means it needs an
evolution as you evolve your schedule
has to evolve with you
you are what you consistently do
and the way to become that person
that you want to build the life that you
want is not just having some
vision board for yourself
it's by actually putting into your
calendar let your
calendar be your bucket list
that if you start actually living this
life and doing these things it leads to
a happy whole life for you
treat your personal
just as important as your business
everything gets put into the calendar
and then adjust
and now you're building the life that
you want
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want tony robbins
best advice on achieving success check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there mr tony robbins tony
welcome aboard man thanks evan great to
be with you
now before getting started i just want
to express my gratitude to you i know
you've done so much for the planet